wir schauen nämlich nicht weg wir helfen
weiter in den menschen die durch die
flut alles verloren haben wir sind vor
ort und zwar genau hier aber weil er in
rheinland pfalz hier wurden die menschen
von der jahrhundertflut am schlimmsten
getroffen auch zwei monate nach der flut
herrschen dort wirklich katastrophale
zustände
und es sind deutschlands vergessene
flutopfer und die politik ist nicht da
die stadtarbeiter acht wochen nach der
jahrhundertflut die menschen dort leiden
weiterhin unter den folgen der
zerstörerischen wassermassen hilfe von
der politik kommt offenbar nicht an
genauso wenig wie die hilfe der
bundeswehr wie kann es sein dass ein
solcher staat wie deutschland seine
bürger so im stich lässt
darüber möchten wir jetzt sprechen und
zwar mit der grünen-politikerin und flut
expertin irene mihalic die uns jetzt
zugeschaltet ist hallo frau michalitsch
wie erklären sie sich dass das nichts
ankommt es wurden ja 30 milliarden
versprochen aber wir waren dort vor ort
haben mit den menschen gesprochen und da
kommt gar nichts an
die 30 milliarden sind ja als paket
progression im deutschen bundestag
beschlossen worden das heißt sie müssen
natürlich jetzt auch auf den weg
gebracht werden und das organisiert sich
so dass dieses hilfspaket jetzt
praktisch über die jeweils zuständigen
bundesländer dann ausgezahlt wird
beziehungsweise entsprechend verteilt
wird aber es ist natürlich dramatisch
dass das erste vor lange gedauert hat
und dass die menschen halt eben vor ort
also nicht nur daran darunter leiden
dass eben diese finanzielle unterschrift
punkt noch nicht oder einfach so lange
auf sich warten lässt man dann auch die
ganze
katastrophenhilfe also wirklich das was
ich vor ort eben auch zeigt dass man zum
beispiel ja den müll weggeräumt dass die
aufbauarbeiten dann nicht wirklich
vorwärts gehen das ist natürlich etwas
was sich in einem organisationsversagen
ausdrückt obwohl ich sagen muss wir
müssen auch unsere katastrophenhilfe und
bodenschutz wirklich komplett neu
aufstellen man wird denn dort was
passieren was meinen sie
es ist ja so dass der katastrophenschutz
in deutschland ländersache ist die
länder wiederum habe diese aufgaben in
den allermeisten fällen auf die kommunen
übertragen und wir haben als grüne ja
schon sehr sehr lange deutlich gemacht
und nicht erst seit dieser fakt hat das
profil sondern auch schon in früheren
fällen dass der bund da wirklich stärker
koordinierend eingreifen muss aber auch
die notwendige mittel dazu bereit
stellen muss dazu müsste aber das
grundgesetz geändert werden damit der
bund diese aufgabe übernehmen kann und
ich hoffe doch sehr dass es dafür in
zukunft auch politische behalten bis
dahin könnte man immerhin bürokratische
hindernisse ausräumen wir waren gestern
vor ort und haben menschen eingeladen zu
einem stammtisch um zu berichten wie es
ihm geht und es waren wirklich zum teil
haarsträubende geschichten die dort
erzählt wurden selbst der schutz den sie
aus ihren kaputten häusern heraus tragen
wird nicht weg gebracht sondern im
gegenteil das ordnungsamt kommt vorbei
und
beklagt dass dann noch
das sind natürlich dinge die sind
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar
selbstverständlich muss man da jetzt mit
dem größtmöglichen faschismus angehen
also das ist auch etwas was uns auch die
helferinnen und helfer widergespiegelt
haben ja dass sie halt eben teilweise
sind ja alles überwiegend ehrenamtliche
menschen die dort tätig sind beim thw
bei den freiwilligen feuerwehren jahren
bei den hilfsorganisationen die dort im
einsatz sind und die machen das ja auch
neben ihrer normalen beruflichen
tätigkeit und das ist natürlich ein
großes engagement was da auf der einen
seite ist aber man sieht natürlich dass
es halt eben in konkreten situationen
oftmals nicht ausreicht und dann sollte
es nicht in der verantwortung
eines landrat liegen oder einzelner
katastrophenschutz über die vor ort
diese hilfe von bundesseite aus von
landesseite aus organisieren zu müssen
und dann müssen wir uns nicht wundern
dass einzelne lokale strukturen mit
dieser aufgabe überfordert sind obwohl
der bund eigentlich die möglichkeit dazu
hat aber gesetzlich daran gehindert ist
diese möglichkeiten auf den linken sie
sind selber politikerin
als die katastrophe passierte haben sich
die politiker alle dort gezeigt und
haben sich in gummistiefeln vor die
kulisse gestellt auch um zu helfen
natürlich aber es sind auch wahlkampf
bilder natürlich
das passt so gar nicht zu dem das die
politik dann hier total versagt
ja da haben sie natürlich recht also
dass man muss natürlich wenn man dort
bord unterwegs ist sollte es in erster
linie darum gehen mit den menschen zu
sprechen
ich habe unsere aktivitäten dort auch so
wahrgenommen unsere kanzlerkandidatin
annalena baerbock bayer auch bord und
hat auch bewusst auf bessere begleitung
verzichtet weil es ja gerade darum ging
eben auch wirklich mit den menschen ja
ungefilterte eindrücke sprechen zu
können und wirklich zu erfahren wie es
den menschen geht und was welche hilfe
jetzt auch benötigt wird und das muss
jetzt auch natürlich passieren also
einfach nur hin zu fahren und sich das
alles anzuhören reichlich und da ist
natürlich die bundesregierung gefragt da
ist aber auch die landesregierung
gefragt damit jetzt auch die hilfe die
versprochen wurde auf bewegt zu bringen
wie gesagt der deutsche bundestag hat
das 30 milliarden hilfspaket beschlossen
ja also das ist sozusagen jetzt in kraft
und jetzt muss es natürlich auch von den
zuständigen behörden entsprechend
ausgezahlt und auch verteilt werden
damit die hilfe auch dort ankommt wo sie
benötigt wird
von den grünen vielen dank und sie haben
es auch angesprochen natürlich wird
jetzt auf jede helfende hand gesetzt und
auch wir von bild lassen die menschen
vor ort natürlich ihn nicht im stich wir
schauen nicht weg sondern helfen im
flutgebiet vor ort in ahrweiler ist
jetzt unsere reporterin daniela fahrt
werden sie eben schon mal gehört
geschalten noch mal zu ihr daniela wie
ist die situation der menschen was
konntest du in erfahrung bringen
die situation hier im aartal in
rheinland pfalz ist nach wie vor
dramatisch viele menschen haben immer
noch kein strom kein trinkwasser die
menschen wissen nicht wie sie den winter
ohne heizung überstehen sollen und wir
stehen jetzt in einer solchen wohnung
eines flut opfers bei kamen teils von
den eichen in arbeit
vielleicht können sie uns einmal
erzählen oder erklären wir stehen jetzt
hier im wohnbereich oder im ehemaligen
wohnbereich was davon noch übrig ist wie
hoch stand hier denn das wasser und was
hat das wasser hier angerichtet ja also
das wasser stand hier im wohnbereich so
circa ein meter fünfzig man kann das
hier noch sehen an dieser kannte und der
keller natürlich auch komplett
vollgelaufen mit schlamm wir hatten aufs
wasser dann heraus war noch so 10 20 cm
schlamm auch im wohnbereich alle möbel
umgefallen diese bucht kann sich keiner
vorher vorstellen alles schwere
schrankwände mit büchern lagen einfach
da das einzige was war retten konnten
ist hier unsere alte familien truhe die
wir hoffentlich gut restauriert bekommen
und ein bisschen geschirr das
ohne brüche überlebt hat denn irgendwie
hängt man ja an jedem stück
ja
sie haben es vorhin schon mal gesagt ein
schaden von 40.000 euro hier ist aber
nicht das schlimmste denn auch unter
anderem fotos sind beispielsweise
verloren gegangen wie sieht es denn mit
finanzieller unterstützung aus haben sie
da schon was bekommen wir
haben sagt man die soforthilfe vom kreis
die kam ziemlich schnell die 1000 euro
die schnell überwiesen worden sind und
dann vom land was wir selber beantragt
haben ist dann auch für meine meinung
für mich 2000 euro bekommen nur kosten
haben wir bis dato haben wir schon über
10.000 euro kosten weil verpflichtend
war ja auch einen neuen stromkasten zu
installieren weil der im kellerbereich
natürlich komplett unter wasser stand
und
wir gott sei dank dann elektriker auch
schnell bekommen haben 19 eingebaut hat
sonst werden wir von vom stromversorger
gar nicht freigeschaltet worden für
strom und auch die heizungsanlage
komplett zerstört die auch schon
ausgetauscht worden ist und wenn man
dann diese insgesamt fast 11.000 euro
die wir jetzt ausgegeben haben in ins
verhältnis setzt mit dem was gekommen
ist vom land
ja also man wird gezwungen in vorkasse
zu gehen jeder und es gibt ja auch
betroffene die die noch größere
wohnungen haben wo größere stromanlagen
größere heizungen sind die ihn noch viel
viel mehr in vorkasse gehen müssen
ja mit diesen eindrücken verabschieden
wir uns hier aus ahrweiler und geben
zurück ins studio nach berlin
[Musik]